work is set to span from the 215 all the
way to the las vegas strip
that is where we find reporter madison
kimbrough tonight with the latest on
what we can expect out on those roads
madison
yes many major roadways will be shut
down and reduced to one lane like right
here on the strip
we spoke to many locals to see how this
affects them and their commute to work
it's not the greatest situation for
locals in las vegas
i usually leave about an hour before i
have to go to work when i work on the
strip
get ready las vegas several roadways
around town are being worked on for
weeks at a time
causing increased traffic and
inconvenience for locals around town
i'm out on the road a lot so i drive a
lot
but it definitely takes a toll starting
monday may 3rd
east wyoming avenue will be closed at
las vegas boulevard
that will last until may 28th one lane
eastbound and one lane westbound will
remain open
but one major roadway project already in
the works is on the strip
the northbound side of las vegas
boulevard is currently limited to one
travel lane
between spring mountain road and resorts
world drive
to be more traffic with more people on
the roads
it's no big deal from my experience i
mean i drive around a lot while these
closures are inconvenient some locals
are staying optimistic
and say they are glad the work is being
done and i am thankful that the roads
are getting fixed and stuff so you know
our car is now just bumping around you
know losing pieces you know losing parts
now as for the specific construction
work on the strip you are looking at it
right now where you can see there is a
construction worker
with the sign that says slow and stop as
they are narrowing it down to
one lane that is expected to wrap up in
a couple months
now as for the reduction to one lane
that's only expected to last for about a
week so you won't have to worry about
that in the next coming months
reporting live from the strip madison
kimbrough 8 news now